si madame la ministre la parole est à
monsieur arnaud vialle pour les
républicains
madame la présidente madame la
présidente mesdames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues sur le
même ministre vous avez décidé de
baisser drastiquement les dotations aux
collectivités
les chiffres parlent d'eux mêmes dit
millions d'euros entre 2014 et 2017 pour
le bloc communal en aveyron 62 millions
d'euros pour le conseil départemental
c'est une mise en faillite programmée
sans plan de redressement possible qui
impacte de plein fouet le tissu
économique local
alors même que vous nous abreuver de
déclarations ont sur la réorganisation
des compétences
la réalité c'est que la loi ne traite un
énorme éléphant qui accouchait d'une
minuscule souris dans le même temps vous
n'avez pas hésité à faire payer aux
contribuables locaux la très contestée
réforme des rythmes scolaires
rien que pour ma commune de 700
habitants la note est salée 28000 euros
pour les activités période indicative
que nous avons souhaité mettre en place
pour infliger à nos enfants une
discrimination supplémentaire car vous
êtes bien coupable de discrimination
lorsque vous annoncé à grand renfort de
déplacement ministériel pompeux des
mesures pour la ruralité
alors même que vous laissez en regagner
la capitale une autre facture salée aux
contribuables locaux celle de
l'équipement en fibres de leur
territoire qui s'élève à + dizaines de
millions d'euros pour chaque communauté
de communes de province et maintenant
les collectivités doivent aussi assumer
vos décisions de politique étrangère
voulait accueillir des migrants
mais ce sont les communes qui doivent
régler l'ardoisé certes l'émotion est
partagée sur ce sujet mais votre arme
c'est la culpabilisation comme en
témoignent les crises et injonctif
doublé de sms préfectoraux reçu par les
maires de france sur leur portable au
cours des deux derniers week-ends ma
question est donc très simple monsieur
le premier ministre
quand arrêterez vous de creuser la
fracture territoriale quand c'est serez
vous de faire supporter à d'autres les
coûts exorbitants de vos décisions
merci monsieur le député la parole et à
marylise lebranchu ministre la
décentralisation la fonction publique
merci à madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les députés mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur débuté
arnaud viala la baisse des dotations aux
collectivités locales c'est un effort
téléphone or juste et c'est un effort
équitable vous faisiez à l'est en
référence aux collectivités rurales
je vous rappelle monsieur le député que
alors qu'effectivement la baisse des
dotations est lourde à porter chacun
hong kong sous l'autorité du premier
ministre nous avons ajouté 117 millions
à la dsr plus encore à la detr dotation
d'équipement des territoires ruraux et
que dix mille communes
dix mille communes grâce à la
péréquation décidé n'ont naturellement
pas vu leurs finances baissé autant je
vous rappelle que les communes rurales
sont appelés effectivement dans leur
ensemble n'ont pas 15 euros par habitant
la baisse des dotations et les
communions de plus de 10000 habitants à
peu près pour 40 euros mais je voudrais
vous dire quelque chose qu'il faut que
nous partagions d'abord la loi note a
été voté par cette majorité et par la
majorité a donc lorsque vous la
critiquer pour critiquer tout le monde
et seconde mans si on veut faire 50
milliards de baisses de dépenses
publiques
il est impossible de faire cette baisse
de dépense publique sans bouger et aux
dotations pourquoi on semble des
dotations et reversements aux
collectivités locales des pinces et 70
milliards c'est-à-dire le montant de
l'impôt sur le revenu des français
les contribuables sont les mêmes et
quand vous nous demandez de faire 100
milliards d'économies 110 ou 130 comme
d'autres alors dites moi comment vous
les frais